Metro reports that a woman met her
boyfriend in a less than thrilling way
Danielle met James on dull men's it's a
Facebook page where self-proclaimed
boring men posts about their interests
some of them range from organizing their
sock drawers to their favorite gas
station
yeah steo what do you think about this
is this I'm guessing this is not where
you and Lux
met it's
not but I can relate I can identify with
being pretty boring when the cameras are
not on when I'm doing my own thing like
chill I'm pretty chill yeah yeah I like
this I really do because listen bottom
line is your relationship is going to
get boring everyone news flash right if
it starts out boring you'll never lose
that spark right just keep it right
right there I like that perspective I
like it too it and honestly like the joy
in a marriage in it is folding the socks
and making sure the drawers are oh look
honey I folded the socks look yeah look
isn't it neat yeah I just recently
discovered that I don't like shoving the
one sock in and butter cupping the other
one over I've had a big life change I'm
really thrilled that you have such an
exciting socks life oh was okay for
Rance but not okay for single people you
haven't been doing anything for seven
years you told us many times if you're
not having sex you're having socks all
right and it's like it might be time to
leave the house that's why I got excited
about that detail I was like there's
other sock Enthusiast out there sign me
up I want you to have I want you to have
socks and sex in your life okay A little
bit of both is healthy don't you think
sure there you go all right and I you
know what might be P pushing people away
about
you where is this going well we all just
experienced this one's for you the
Washington Post asked do you want to
burp
[Laughter]
less
well yep well they listed a bunch of
tips to help and uh I think we all know
someone who could use them take a look
at
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this wow I've never seen him like that
before that was such a
treat doo I love you so much I cannot
believe you're at the desk here I mean
this is just such a thrill we've known
each other a long time I love what
you've put out into the world but this
special is it is special and I can't
wait for everybody to see it sto's
bucket list at sto.com is out now and up
next potato tot um croutons that's all
you need to know we'll be right
[Music]
back